here is tylor mcgill his first seven
starts this year the mets won six of
those seven games and his era was 2.04
in the last seven the mets have dropped
five of those seven starts and his era
is almost six and a half
on the outside corner at the knees and
that turns le mayhew away ted barrett is
walking out toward the mound and there
may be some sort of light flashing in
center field studio set up there and
it's somewhat in the batter's eye so
they'll try and rectify that situation
everybody should everybody vacated the
studio there's nobody there turning to
turn the switch didn't your mother tell
you
when you leave the room turn out the
light yes he's runner on third less than
two outs looking to drive the ball he's
waiting for something middle middle
right here
he does swing at it wraps it up the
middle it'll produce a run
as judge is thrown out at first 1-0x
jordan montgomery comes in with a record
of five and five from late june through
mid-july he lost four straight starts in
seven starts since then he's 2-0 with an
era of one and a half two aboard for
alonso
struck him out so twice he's gone
three-and-oh and then come back to fan
first lindor and now alonso so now baez
two on two out another 2-2 pitch
line drive base hit vr around third
being waved home the throw is going to
get him
that is that now is arguing that he got
in there because sanchez did not get
that tag low and ted barrett is saying
he tagged him in the helmet if i were
the mets i take a real good look here
you know what vr may have a case i think
he does he is safe
here's joey
this ball is drilled by joey gallo and
forget about it
first pitch home run
it's his 32nd of the season his seventh
as a yankee that mcgill loves to throw
first pitch strikes and that the curve
balls the rare pitch he'll throw as a
get me over pitch
well
joey galloway said i'm not gonna give
you that pitch
i'm gonna ambush that curveball yeah get
me over and i'm gonna hit it over the
fence get me over get me out the ball on
the strike to him struck out looking to
start the game
bounce to vr at third
flip across the diamond that's the
second out
in the yankee third aaron judge to the
plate for the yanks
judge strikes out
fifth strikeout for mcgill the bases are
loaded on a single on a pair of walks
and now no margin of error against
alonso
he
an
walks
opening single by vr and then
consecutive walks to lindor conforto and
alonso tie the game
abibaya's single to left to tie the game
in the first
bouncing ball urchella has it he throws
to the plate that gets by sanchez only
one run will score the bases will remain
loaded herschel made a good play at the
start
but then an errant throw in sanchez
trying to hold the plate with his right
foot and then lunge out with the glove
couldn't reach it
mcneil punches a bunt to the right side
and everything goes right for the mets
in this inning how about that as i
channel mel allen base is still loaded
still nobody out the o2 pitch
a drive to left back goes gallow he
takes it it'll be a sacrifice fly
and the mets have their fourth run of
the inning neal advancing to second no
balls in a strike on james mccann this
one is stroked into the left field
corner by mccann
pilar comes home from second base it's
an rbi double
it's a five run inning and it's six to
two
and doors the batter with one out nobody
on the pitch
lindor lifts one down the right field
line yes and it's out of here
just inside the pole
for his 14th home run of the season
didn't drop the bat until he saw the
home run signal he's been out front on
off speed pitches so much
that's staying back on fastball he does
right here hit it late hit it out great
approach great result
not in this yard
baez drives one toward the gap in right
center field one bounce against the wall
conforto rounds third he's being waved
home the peg to the plate will not be in
time the throw to third
gets baez trying to move up and puts an
end to the inning but not before the
mets tack on yet another run full count
to mccann
and he strikes out looking pitcher spot
due
no he's going to hit and he's going to
hit yeah there's no reason to take tyler
mcgill out of this game
a little number to the right side le
mayhew gobbles it up miguel doesn't run
hard and nobody expects him to and
that's the ending
2-1
this could be a double play ball even
with gardner running low throw safe
first pitch to judge bouncing ball to
third the are backhands throws to second
base one baez to first two a double play
aaron judge hits one five four three
around the horn
mcgill reaches the seventh
and if anything getting better as the
game has moved along
2-2 rizzo swings and misses strike three
good back doors change-up it said there
from mcgill kind of moved like his
slider did down and into the lefty rizzo
that's strikeout number nine
and this is joey gallows life a homer
and a pair of strikeouts that power
four-seam fastball and just overpowered
yellow the bases are loaded
and mccann possible double play ball le
mayhew to torres high throw
gets by
and another run scores
should have ended the inning but it's
been that kind of night and that kind of
stretch for the yankees
strike on fred gardner first and second
one out in the eighth let's lead 10 to
two
gardner pops it up
left center field sends pilar back a few
steps still angling to his right as he
backs up makes the catch
voight thought about attacking but he'll
stay at second and there's two outs
[Applause]
shallow right field coming on as
conforto and he makes a tumbling couch
so judge is retired he's over four for
the night and where he had been
streaking just like his clubs suddenly
he's slumping so we go to the top of the
ninth here's rizzo
[Applause]
rizzo with a drive to deep right if it's
fair it's a home run
and that's just what it is so anthony
rizzo with his 20th home run of the
season his sixth as a yankee his second
in as many nights hit one last night in
the bronx
against the blue jays pads his stats
although likely in a losing effort makes
it 10-3
who's to argue
sanchez skies one to right
pallar waits and the mets who took two
out of three in july at yankee stadium
in the first of the subway series
meetings have won the first one here
[Applause]